[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
i'm link and i'm red this week at the
round table of dim lighting we
are doing what we've done for the past
couple of years which is
give our top 10 moments
of the year yes i i've been looking
forward to this we each have
10 so there's 20 total i'm a fan of
nostalgia even if it's short-term
nostalgia i think
just looking back at 12 months when it
comes to nostalgia you got to say
that's pretty short-term right i don't
consider it nostalgic i like the process
of looking back
like i look back through my photos you
saw me doing this yesterday i look back
through my calendar
i look back through my digital journal
and thoughts
i don't really call it a journal i'll
just like
you know diary you call it a little
diary i have notes
little diary on my computer and i just
have one note that's called
thoughts and some sometimes that i date
it so it's basically a journal i just
don't have the guts to call it a journal
because i'll just feel guilty for not
not actually keeping up with it so i
just call it i got a journal that i
don't keep up with
uh you don't need i mean just make a
journal entry everyone just
just because you don't feel guilty about
something don't make me feel guilty
about it
i'm saying i got a whole folder in my
evernote are you using evernote
okay i'll say it i use an evernote um
and i got a list of 10 things yeah i
don't want to sit here and talk about
evernote when we got some amazing things
that have happened to us
in an amazing year well hasn't this been
a great year 2020
unlike any other there was i've got to
tell you honestly
uh in previous years i have had
difficulty
narrowing it down to like my top 10
moments yeah
i had trouble coming up with 10. i mean
i listen i mean it has been a good year
for us
you know relative to a lot of folks yeah
but this has been a tough year for
a lot of people and uh it i started
some of the things that made the list it
was like i think it's
they made the list given the
the year given the state of 2020. it's
like oh
normally you wouldn't think that that
would make the list but boy
what a year like this year it's a
highlight well
and i really haven't i know we call it
the top 10
but it's i i've thought of as like top
10 most
impactful moments or
so you change the things memories you
changed it from the past two years
no i i think that i think that it's i
mean it's milestone moments yeah they're
they're not all there's something that's
big and enjoyable right
you know i think i i focused on the
positive personally just because i felt
like it was a negative year so
there may be some things that didn't
make the list that seem monumental that
i just was like
hell i ain't put it on my list no this
is definitely
a positive list that i've worked up as
well but i mean there's some
well how do i put it i i there's some
that
are uh you know there's there's been
some valleys of
of darkness in this year and i just
wanted to acknowledge that
in in some of what i put in here but
it's mostly silver lining
okay it's mostly silver lining so
we're just going to alternate you know
it's not true that clouds have us
if if clouds have a silver lining that's
a that's like an environmental problem
well that means there's like silver
oc dioxide or something that somehow
through some mining process
got into the cloud that you don't want
to be breathing that in i think the
problem is yours
being that you can't you can't even find
the silver lining in
a silver silver line there's silver
lining it's a
is a problematic analogy it's a sun
behind the cloud
i think about silver being the content
of the cloud having silver in it i
didn't think i needed to explain this
it a silver lining lets you know that
there is a sun
behind the cloud it's a bright spot
that you just have to trust is going to
come out again and make you warm and
and happy and better in 2021. if you
drink too much colloidal silver it can
make you blue i think there was a guy
that was on like donahue
back in the 90s are you stalling are you
afraid not to celebrate
no i'll go first as a matter of fact
we do need to get started because i mean
there's 20 things on this list there's
no reason to
there's no reason to talk about silver
linings join us
hashtag your biscuits let us know what
what your milestone
moments of 2020 are but go first
number 10 for me uh
is a moment that i talked about the the
vacation that we took
to uh to san diego with my family
and uh there was the moment that i got
to surf for the first time
with both of my boys locking shepard
shepard's first time ever
surfing and uh there was just a moment
they were out there
and i'm like i mean nobody's really
killing it nobody's really
ripping it no one's doing anything that
they would write home about or
want to be videoed but there were
dolphins i remember
no that was a different time oh the
dolphin swimming alongside me is i think
the highlight of my life
and that was not this year it was
previous yeah some other year but i
lobbed that at you as an opportunity i'm
sure there were dolphins
revision history it well there were
dolphins like
probably in our midst also something i
learned
that week while we were surfing is that
there was this year especially
an unusually high number of
juvenile great white sharks that are
swimming
amongst the swimmers and surfers all
along the california coast can we just
take the words juvenile and great
and just replace them both with one word
they cancel each other out
white sharks yeah um fledgling white
sharks
but it turns out that these
juvenile great white sharks are not
aggressive towards humans
usually so anyway uh
but anyway having this moment with my
kids doing something
that i felt like you know i talked about
the the you know pushing
shepherd and him catching a wave and
then there was the next day that
we went out all three of us surfing
together it's a special moment doing one
of my favorite things with two of my
favorite people
number ten my number oh are we already
we're already to my number ten um
yeah i mean with with covid hitting i
don't know if you remember covid hit
this year yeah it's still kind of
hitting of course people are saying that
it was here in
in december of 2019 they're really
they're really starting to figure that
out
right right right right man we can't not
talk about covet in this thing
but one big silver lining once we really
started to hunker down
you know i this is not one of my moments
but i remember we talked about it just
like
looking watching the news and processing
in real time with the rest of the world
trying to make sense of what is
beginning to happen
and news anchors saying get ready this
is your new normal
and as much as i was trying to process
it
you just kind of have to live it and so
as it starts to sink in
oh man this has been a month this has
been two months i remember when we would
count
how many weeks we had been without going
out
or you know being in contact with people
or
each other um and it was
in that context that my number 10
happened
which is we instituted a weekly zoom
call with our college
friends ah yes um thanksgiving of 2019
when i went home i reconnected with with
a couple of the guys
in person and i gave a teaser to like
some things we're going to be talking
about in your biscuits which
i'm sure will uh the logistics podcast
which i'm sure we'll talk more about in
a little bit
and just kind of reconnecting let them
know where where we were at and how we
were going to
go public with this type of stuff and it
and then it we just then we started a
text group
as as as those podcasts came out but
then it turned into
a zoom chat that you know everybody
didn't make it every week
um especially at certain key points
for me it was it was uh
it was it was a big deal to be able to
reconnect with friends
just just laugh and reminisce and
uh you know talk about how we're
processing this thing
right and know that you've got someone
that uh
that we knew so well and then
reconnecting it was like picking up
right where we left off with those guys
um you know you got greg our
our college roommate tim who was the
second college roommate who moved in
with us you got
uh harm who who came along with new kirk
at the other there was the
like the sister apartment that that they
lived in that
uh that we would connect with and hang
out with and got into all types of
trouble
that's the that's the apartment that we
were in when we made the decision to
drop
the poop off at the party that we talked
about right
so i you know it's um
it was therapeutic and it is therapeutic
to
to keep that friendship going you know
especially when
you d when there was a time when it's
like there wasn't a lot to look forward
to in the week and
you re we really needed that that level
of connection
and now you know we've we've revived the
friendship to a point that
uh it's something that we cherish and
it's it's active
i wonder how many people have um
i wonder how many people reconnected in
that way
this year i have to believe that
i mean i know that there's a thing where
people are like reconnecting with
friends that they used to see
in person like hey let's have a let's
have a cocktail hour
or let's have a little zoom let's have a
dinner party on zoom
um we've done a little bit of that but
but yeah connecting it's
it's funny because we and i also hung
out with a couple of the guys we went to
an nc state basketball game
when i went back for christmas for
christmas yep
uh new car can harm and i met and went
to a game
and um so we would see each other in
that capacity but yeah it's it's funny
how
we were we were talking just the other
day because we've had a few we still
have a lot of meetings all the time
just in the professional sense and a
couple of the meetings that we were
going to be
zoom calls ended up being scheduled as
phone calls uh
and then it just felt so strange to just
be on a conference call with people like
hold on what let's do this as a video
call
i actually got angry inside that i
couldn't see the people i was talking
about what what are we in 2019 well it
is
it's amazing how quickly i almost felt
like i can't have a conversation with
just someone's
voice you know within the span of one
year less than a year
all of a sudden the capacity to just
talk to somebody on the phone without
seeing their face
it's amazing how this is just a cultural
revolution but i think it was like oh
i'm talking to my co-workers employees
business partners through this medium
why can't i do that with old friends why
can't i do that with
i mean they were all spread out across
the country we got north carolina
missouri we got washington we got japan
you know we all hop on the call
and um it it it really gave a sense of
connectedness i mean it's one thing to
talk to your family
but the way that you can at least for me
the way that i'm able to open up with
that friend group
and kind of process and it be this
trusted environment
where it's like you know we're just
friends it's like it's
you can have that with different family
members i i i don't have that
so it's you know it's it's it was nice
to have that and also to kind of track
their experience with where they are
physically in the world
because every state is a little bit
different it didn't matter if you were
new kirk over there in japan
or if you were in uh missouri or here
it's you were having there was a shared
experience that
but it was a little bit different and
you started to put your finger on the
pulse of like
how things really are back at home
and and really assessing that so it i
mean it was connected on a relational
sense but also
in like uh uh a so
like a a a a social
socio global sense social global social
you know
that's that's my number ten okay uh my
number
nine is uh
this is gonna get a little bit cryptic
because i'm gonna tell you something but
not tell you fully what it was
and uh relatively recently i'd say in
the past month do i get credit for this
do you get credit for it yeah i had to
remind you of this
oh i thought you get do you get credit
for the i you get
credit for adding the idea to the to the
list reminding you that it should be on
your list yeah no you didn't
because that's another one that's also
going to be cryptic oh dang you got a
bunch of crypts
i got two cryptic things okay all right
so what's what is this
this is where you and i now
i i'm gonna i mean this is a twofer
because i'm also gonna talk about the
creative house like
this was the year of the creative house
which has been a godsend for us
having a place that we could go that is
um
not our homes and not our office it's a
it's a homey office i believe we moved
in in um
february that makes sense maybe late
january and so the timing was just
serendipitous that it happened to work
out in the year of
covid that we had this place that we
could go
um and
we've had some good solid creative time
there
and uh relatively recently we
spent an afternoon conceptualizing
an idea for a movie that we would like
to make
you know this we've always got things
that we're trying to do we got things
we're trying to get off the ground
yeah and we spent
i don't know how long it was i mean it
did it took us about an hour to and
no no more than two hours with this full
this full discussion
of kind of unpacking um
boy if this movie gets made
then we'll have to release the recording
of of us coming up with the
idea because we did record it yeah i
mean the
the idea has shifted a little bit but uh
oh sure we could release it
it is you know it's a good idea when
you're like hold on let's
let's record this conversation like just
audio well you also know it's a good
idea when
like the next day you're like
you sleep on it you're like is this idea
too crazy
is this idea yes is this idea too crazy
for us to do
yes but let's do it anyway right and i
think that's kind of where we're at so
anyway we
can't do it alone though and you can't
guarantee that it will ever get done but
even that feeling
i it's not on my list but it should be
it was i mean
we're i mean we're moving forward we
keep talking about it we're we're adding
some meat to those bones
and uh it was just a you know
the the busier that we've gotten you
know
in spite of how do i say this
we haven't traveled because of covid we
haven't toured we haven't done a lot of
the things that would normally really
make our schedule
super packed which made twizzy what
things that made 2019
an extraordinarily packed year right
there was so much
there was so much travel a lot of
touring
but you would think that we would have
replaced all that time with all this
unfettered creative time and really what
it's been replaced with
is struggle just you know trying to
maintain a business
and a show in the midst of all the
turmoil
trying to keep trying yeah trying to
keep it afloat what's going
going on and it has taken more of our
time than i think we ever anticipated
but
dana and it took a huge emotional toll
because i there was this pervasive
undercurrent of emotion and anxiety that
was like
are we doing enough to preserve
and uh you know and we
we discussed this i mean if you go back
through the podcast of this year i think
it was something that was just always
there beneath the service when we
weren't discussing it and that was
what what did we what you were
constantly reacting to news
and um requirements and
guidelines and restrictions
and just feeling the weight of
making decisions for not only for us and
our families but for
a you know for all of our employees and
it it was it was a lot man and yeah
we i and then you add on i
feel like i feel like we should be able
to
capitalize on this and be more creative
we should write a whole
screenplay or this that and the other
yeah and we
have been that was part of the struggle
yeah we and we have been
and again another one of my items on the
list we'll we'll allude to this but
we have been able to conceptualize some
things that we're excited about
uh but that the the rapid
there was something about the nature of
the way that this particular idea was
birthed
um and there was just this reckless
abandon
and commitment to just like let's just
follow this
and not judge ourselves or the idea
as it's happening we'll do that tomorrow
and uh yeah it was just again
it's unf it was an unfettered creative
exercise that led to what could be we've
had a lot of dumb ideas
what could be one of our stupider ideas
but hopefully stupid in a smart way
and uh hopefully something that will
will get made
i i will be however many months or years
from now will be
like hey yeah we made that we made that
movie man i think the
yeah that brainstorming session
it really represents the um
not culmination but kind of like the and
what's the word i'm looking for it's
like the payoff like the uh
the realization of the vision of
renting this creative house that it was
a place where we could go
and isolate and um
not worry about being interrupted and
just unabashedly
just come up with stuff and it was just
it was fun you know it's so much of what
we do
now in terms of our creative work is
compartmentalized like literally on a
calendar
this is this is how much this is when
you've got to start
and this is when you got to stop and
even if you don't start when you need to
start
this is when you need to stop because
there's something right after it that
you got to move on to
yeah and it it pressurizes things in a
way that
you know it's you start to use that
pressure can lead to frustration when
you don't
when you have to move away from it or
you have to
or it's just not going well or nothing
nothing comes from it but to give
ourselves permission
in the physical space to just
get just have a pure
creative conversation and then say
and that be the objective and then for
something
crazy and beautiful and and
potentially career
melding to come out of it
i mean i would say is is is just a bonus
because the experience itself was uh was
was worthy of
of being in in in anybody's top 10 list
did it make yours no
okay well all right so are you gonna go
ahead and tell them uh
pitch the idea no tell them what the
movie's about i'm not going to
tell them tell them who stars in it i'm
not going to say anything
i mean just give them one word give them
one word so that when it comes back
when it comes when it when they start to
hear about it if it ever happens
they'll remember they'll have
confirmation
that that that thing was this thing
a guy no okay that's
a guy i know a guy wakes up
okay all right all right that'll work
i don't think i don't think that part
will change
yeah you could though
all right so i'm gonna go to my number
nine man this is gonna take a while but
i promise it's gonna be worth it
and if it's not just stop listening but
some of mine are but the way that we've
structured this
is that we're counting up which implies
that the moments get more meaningful to
us as we go so
even if you don't like what we've talked
about so far chances are
greater inc they increase as we go on
that's weird but first let's promote
some merch
oh you want to do that uh we got these
myth of cups
if you pour cold water into them they
change color this one
only where the cold water touches this
turns purple and this one turns blue
that one turns red no one turns purple
um
we both have a blue one wouldn't it be
cool if you poured something coal in it
and it just incinerated
that's a 2021 idea we got to get these
we gotta we got to get rid of this stock
i think that that's just making
something out of like rice paper or
something
disintegrating cups you pour water on
something and it burns
oh and then finding out how to burn
water
mythical.com get yourself something to
drink out of these are
these are nestable they're stackable
here and that's those other two man come
on
look at that you could probably stack
them 100 high if you want this right
here
these four cups which they come in a set
of four but don't wash them like that
uh don't wash one of them don't wash
them like that
mythical.com has got everything you
would need spend that
christmas money
okay number nine my number nine
is um something that
and are you looking at my list don't
look over my list listen to what i'm
saying i can't help it
why you're like cheating at my list you
want me to say what it is no
okay it's kind of my thing to say what
my thing is well i wasn't going to say
it i was just looking at it
now you can interject and say now do i
get credit for this
it's like that's cool you accidentally
can't turn the subtitles off to a movie
you can't help but read them yeah i hate
that
you're like oh man i totally understand
everything they're saying but i have to
read it as well
the one i wouldn't say the one but the
i would say this is the preeminent
constant
of covid for the neil family
i mean and we never talked about it we
never talked about
like setting a rule or an expectation
that this is the one thing that we as a
family are going to fixate on
and it is going to align us it is going
to be it is going to create
a family meeting it's going to create
something where we will come together
and everyone will be motivated to be in
the same room with everybody else
every single night hold on you do it
every night week night
even weekends when the conversation we
have to have is
not are we going to come together to
fixate on this but
we have to have conversations when we're
not going to heads up
i've got something so we're not going to
be able to all get together
for this thing that is the the life
force
of the neil family handcuffs you did it
that often
say what it is survivor
a television show reality competition
show i don't know if you've heard of it
um
two years ago at the uh at the end of
2018
we went on a sedona trip i'm sure i
talked about it at the beginning of 2019
and i i remember talking about how we
started watching and
uh so that's when we started we watched
the
um millennials versus gen x and then we
were like hooked on it and then i was
like we're gonna keep watching survivor
and we never did
we never went back to it and then i just
remembered
you know we talked about we had so much
fun watching survivor we're gonna start
watching
i'm sure i talked about this whenever we
did the podcast from home
i told you at that time that we started
watching survivor well let me tell you
now
we are still watching survivor how many
seasons have you gone through this year
um we went back and we started with i
think
season i i did some research on
like if we were gonna binge watch but
like skip the yeah
the most boring ones you started
watching
the most recent episode which was like
an all-star season with like winners and
stuff and
fan favorites or whatever it is those
are winners and i said i know how the
meals
all the seasons yeah it sport all the
seasons i didn't
i'm not gonna sit with my family and
watch every season and i so and i was
like
listen i know that's going to work for
the mclaughlins but for the nils i know
how we are
if i can get the family re-hooked on
survivor
then it can be our thing for covet and
again i really really
i did i said i think this may be the
case i want to do some research
and then i said we're going to start
with seasons i think it's 17 it may be
19.
um the first hd season and then
we started watching through skipping the
ones that
the consensus said sucked and then we
got to a certain point and we said we're
even going to watch the ones that suck
because
we're such a fan of survivor now that
we're just going to watch them all so
because i don't want to run out
are you going to go sd all the way
you're going to go no i'm
we're still moving forward in time
you're not going back to standard
definition
standard definitions for success i don't
it's going to that'll be that that'd be
a difficult
it'll be worse than a phone call if we
have to do it we'll do it but
we've watched survivor since since that
point in quarantine
until now again it it is our default
expectation
that we are going to watch it every
single night and so
so do you like jeff probst more or less
now oh more i would love to meet you you
can't get enough probes i can't get
enough of this guy i think he's great i
feel like i know him
i love i love the show it has something
for everybody in our family
it aligns us it's a powerful force and
it's
it's a great show and your teenagers
have not tried to stop this lily
lily and lincoln love it too yeah no my
family had a great time watching
a season but i don't but if we try to do
it every night that would be
that would cause problems for us that's
my number nine
um and i'm keeping i'm i'm gonna keep
going
like i'm not really gonna hit rock
bottom unless
for some reason like
come halfway through 2021 we run out of
survivor
and then we're we're still somehow
you're saying when your life turns back
to normal which
will happen sometime in 2021 i don't we
won't keep watching survivors
every single night he's a female because
they'll be like kids they'll be going to
school they'll have life
yeah and my daughter hopefully will go
off to college
maybe she'll stick around for a survivor
yeah
yeah you can't argue to think about the
effect you're having on these kids
number eight um i alluded to this
in the episode we recorded about all the
purchases we've made on amazon
cooking for me is a general highlight
i'll zero in or home in or even hone in
on one particular moment but
i think cooking has been a home cooking
i'm sure cone cooking home cooking
has been a big part of a lot of people's
lives this year right
you're not going out to well some of you
if
you're like us not going out to
restaurants doing a lot of takeout maybe
but i think there's only so much takeout
that you can do or afford and so a lot
of people
are like well i'm gonna figure out how
to cook myself and
you know we finished our we finally
finished the outdoor area i've got my
little
grill smoker area out there that was
featured in an episode of fancy fast
food with josh
mythical chef josh and um
i'm really enjoying you know i go out
there i play music
and i cook i mean over thanksgiving i
you cook in the house too though i cook
in the house but there's just something
about that outdoor area you know i
i brined and injected and smoked a
turkey
over thanksgiving i also deep fried two
breasts
uh i think the one thing i say that was
a good the one
for mike and jenny turned out would not
be nearly as dry
by the way i got a report on that but
anyway
has so much joy making that and then is
that your claim to fame
like is that what that's your thing you
said you were
homing in on one thing you're you're
talking about determining no no no no no
the thing that the thing i think is the
bigger highlight
um was when i was able to cook those um
the nashville hot chicken sandwiches for
your family and my family
i was there for that um i think that's
the best tasting thing that i've ever
personally made i've made some good
tasting things
i'll vouch for that but there's
something and if you cook on a regular
basis you can relate to this my
uh my mother-in-law used to say this all
the time and i never understood she's an
incredible
cook and we would sit down to eat and
be like this is so good and she'll be
like it's not that good if you've been
cooking it all day
and i was like that's interesting i have
found that to be the case
that if you spend all this time with
this thing and then you serve it a lot
of times it's not as satisfying if
somebody else did it and gave it to you
i don't understand how you're on to it
i don't understand the psychology of
that
so usually even if something is really
good to other people
like i'll be a little bit disappointed
in it
those nashville hot chicken sandwiches
that i pickle brined
the thighs for like six hours deep fried
them in peanut oil
served them on uh hawaiian roll
hawaiian buns with a little bit of
comeback sauce and some dill pickles
it's the best thing i've ever made and i
had so much joy making it and so much
joy
serving it that you tricked yourself
into eating it as if you didn't make it
no i'm saying it was so good that it
overcame that psychological barrier
if you do say so yourself no i do say so
myself well you can
i was there hey it was good um i mean
i'm not gonna take credit for it it was
a recipe people who get
really excited about being able to
follow a recipe is like
somebody following directions to a town
and being like hey look at what i did
you know i invented a town right you
didn't invent the town you just follow
directions to get there
you're not the mayor because you took
map quest
so what are you doing so what i'm saying
is
is that cooking i've discovered the joy
of cooking
it isn't that a book by julia child
uh no it's uh it's a website like google
maps but people don't use it
the joy of cooking map questions talking
about
um so yeah the joy of cooking in 2020 is
one of my highlights in fact number
eight
i'm gonna skip to number four for time
just kidding
okay what no what number am i i'm on
number okay i'm after you
uh and what you said reminding me
i mean a milestone again not on my list
we we launched the mythical kitchen
channel at the top of this year
yeah we did and i'm i'm super proud of
those people yeah make it happen
yeah speaking of the joy josh even
nicole and trevor over there
even nicole intro now they're doing
they're doing great stuff
um my number eight is
we launched our vlogs now they went away
and i run the risk of disappointing
yeah just bringing up opening a wound
opening a wound that you know we made an
announcement
towards the end from our from our
handheld phones
filmed in separate locations you at your
home me and my home saying hey you know
what this is
this has gotten away from what we wanted
to do what we wanted this to be
and yeah we haven't gone back to it um
but it was it was a special era and
you know to to make those vlogs a few
that stand out for me
finding the rat in the attic like i'm
i'm super proud of
uh you taking a shower at my house
you're helping me find out
a rat at my house and
us going off-roading with shepard one of
the last ones that we filmed
before we went into quarantine and then
we started you know
trying to do things every week
separately and it and we weren't
under a lot of pressure yeah yeah we
lost the joy of it
it just didn't it wasn't the outlet it
was supposed to be because it was
oh my gosh what are we going to do now
and it's not really about what we want
to do together
it's about what we can do to make do and
that's not what this was about
i'm glad we stopped doing it and we can
we we reserve the right to pick it up
and do it whenever we want to do it and
release something over there
and uh i'm sure we'll do that
but i look back on those videos
especially those that i mentioned and
like the skin walls one did really well
and
but you know it was a it was a little
different than the other ones but
uh i look back on that really fondly
you know i do as well it it you know
i didn't put it on my i don't know
exactly why i didn't put it on my list
and i think
that i have a little bit of uh i
associate some negative energy
with that because i know how the the
folks who really liked it feel about the
fact that we did it and then stopped
yeah and so yeah i do feel i don't know
shame maybe shame is the word
um but i but i i like that you're seeing
uh seeing it for what it was and how
special it was as it was happening
and like you said hey i'll go ahead and
tell you we already filmed one
we we we if we haven't finished filming
it but there is going to be at least
another one
i don't know when it's going to come out
but
in fact we've got a cut in our inbox
that we need to review right that's
right
that's right so there is going to be at
least another one
it's just how regular is it going to be
i don't know i'm filming another one too
and you've got one that you've been
working on yeah so
something else didn't make the list is
that like well
it reminds me i an honorable mention was
there there's an
there is a furry addition to the neil
household yeah that happened of the
feline variety
and there's a lot i've been holding back
a lot there
right but we're gonna including putting
in my top ten but we're gonna put it
we're gonna let it loose on them
that's the plan even saying this i i
hope will help me follow through with
that yeah i feel like you know what
committing to it
because we filmed we filmed a couple
like we had the idea
whenever we were focused on doing
original tick tocks
yeah we filmed some stuff like once we
started getting back together and we
were
we were trying our hand at that we
decided to document that i know that i
i hate that i'm saying this because it's
just going to frustrate people but
there's
there's a decent amount of footage
associated with us doc
we started documenting the process of
figuring out tick-tock and then
that fizzled out i mean just because or
we reallocated our ourselves to other
things
sometimes we squeeze our tubes a little
too hard we squeeze we
squeeze too hard us being the tubes yeah
and
you will you will hear about in fact my
next one
you'll understand maybe why we you know
some other places that the tube was
getting squeezed oh my goodness
so you know that's just the thing what
to me one of the themes
of of our experience this year is
just trying to figure out what it is we
need to be investing in
yeah investing our time in uh creatively
business-wise uh personally
and just trying to balance and and
maintain some sort of semblance of
of a personal well-being
and not really being able to quantify
how much how much effort and time and
care we need to allocate to ourselves
and our families uh
in order to hold things together
internally and externally you know i
just
it was just it was the thing that we
talked about but
it turns out you couldn't have talked
about it enough and i think that that's
you know with the things that we did do
it it was it was always running parallel
with this
assessment of is this the right thing to
do
or you know because so much was up in
the air and changing so much but
well i can use that as a segue into my
uh number seven because i feel like the
reason we started doing the vlogs
was there was this you know
we're always working on things
there's very few idle moments in the
business
day for us and we talked before about
all the things that we work on that
don't see the light of day because
they're done
and they're not just things that we make
for youtube they're things that involve
working with other people developing
things that gatekeepers you know more
traditional media stuff and
i think that after many years of doing
that there's a little bit of
frustration that like man everybody
moves so slow and
it's hard to convince people to let us
make things and let's do something else
on youtube and i think that the vlogs
kind of came out of a little bit of
creative frustration
but then covet
really complicated it and made it
difficult for us to even be together
and so and and then it was around the
same time we were realizing that like
this is becoming an obligation a weekly
obligation
uh and it's also like well we still want
to do
other creative things and i don't want
to again there's only so much toothpaste
in the tube so
uh there was a confluence
of factors that led to that but one of
them is a real positive thing
and again i'm going to be cryptic again
but i cannot take credit for this one
over
you can take credit for adding this one
to the list yes your list i did not have
it on my list
and uh i don't remember when this
process started but i believe it was
started in 2019
yeah uh that we became friends
with uh a person who
has a rather storied television
career creating some iconic television
shows
and someone whose television shows that
they have created
are there's very little crossover with
anything that fits
our sensibility or tone and you would be
like
huh that's interesting that's not
anything like i've seen rhett link
create but we decided
wouldn't it be fun and weird and strange
and exciting
to work together to create a show that
is like
where does the world of this person's
ideas meet the world of rhett link's
ideas so we're talking and
by show you mean television show
television show yeah and so
we have developed a television show
we have yeah we have developed we had a
series of zoom calls where we would just
well we we i don't remember how it
started
what was the nugget of an idea it was
how
what if we did something to collaborate
together uh
and we had a nugget of an idea and we
kind of pushed it
his way right well it doesn't matter
i don't remember exactly how that the
initial ball got rolling but i do
remember he sent over like a
uh like a couple paragraphs of a
write-up that was like an initial idea
then we kind of took that
and put our spin on it and then
it became this totally
i mean whether or not this becomes a
television show or not uh which we will
be trying very hard in 2021 to get
people to
make this show uh it has been one hell
of a process and very
very fun the world that we have created
is very
deep and strange and funny
and the thing that has been a joy for me
has been being able to
work with this person who has so much
experience and
and specific skill in the area of
writing and creating television and
um you know
we took a stab at writing the pilot
and you know we kind of go on
instinct and some experience and also
it's not like we don't read about the
process of what makes good writing
but there was just something about being
able to hand something over
to this guy and get his
insights and notes on something i felt
like i just i felt like i went to school
this year in a real good way and learned
a whole lot
about the the writing process yeah and
we have a pilot
to show for it literally we have a
script for a pilot
we haven't made it yet that's right yeah
we have a pilot script to show for it
but you know it was yeah it was it was a
cool experience not only getting notes
but like
to get audio notes that were
like kind of a stream of consciousness
kind of like
this is how oh this is how he approaches
this is how he thinks about it and this
is what needs to change it was
a thrill and since you're since you're
much more of a writer
that's why i was like this needs to be
on your list yeah it was i
in and and this was um
i don't know this has been a bit this
has been a big chunk of my time you know
this is this
i put a lot of we both have put a lot of
time into it
um when you ask the question of like
what does red link do all the time
well one of the things is we work on
stuff like this the conclusion i've come
to about this one
is uh and i've been thinking about this
with some some of our
other things that we've developed like
you know we wrote a pilot
for a a show about musical therapy
like seven or eight years ago right when
we were trying to make our first
go at like hollywood besides uh
commercial kings
yeah and we wrote this we've got that
pilot i don't know it's probably not any
good we should dig that up but like
digging that up and doing like a
some kind of reading or something good i
i think maybe put it on the society that
would be a good thing for the society
we'll figure it out uh but the this is
legitimate
that's what we call it the name of the
town was called legitimate but it
obviously had a double meaning yeah but
this idea the movie idea again these
things will probably never see the light
of day
but i i'm believing that both of them
will so who's hoping that both
who is the guy are you going to tell the
people who the guy is nope i'm not
and i i'm a little fuzzy on why we can't
but it's just like
you've got to keep the lid on these
things and i understand that and like
so i'm sorry if you're frustrated don't
they're not frustrated there's a tease
it just gives them something to look
forward to when we are able to announce
it
my number seven uh is
the jimmy fallon hug
[Music]
um whenever we you know whenever we had
to move
our production to our homes
we were like of course we're gonna do
this and this is an opportunity
and uh a lot of this podcast for those
weeks i think we would we would unpack
the discovery that this is tough
you know it's it's this is demanding
this is
this is more demanding than we
anticipated this is exhausting
this is frustrating
and it's yeah it was um it was
it it was there were fun points but it i
remember getting up the morning that we
were going to be on the tonight show
without leaving our respective homes
we were gonna institute the split screen
from that we're employing for gmm and we
were gonna make a three-way split screen
and then we had this idea to like
bring in arms and and like get jimmy to
be in the middle
and then give us a hug and jesse's arm
came over your shoulder and lily's arm
came over my shoulder
and it seemed like it worked it seemed
like jimmy had like really
short arms and feminine hands
giving us a hug and um but i remember
getting up that morning and
it wasn't the only thing we had to shoot
but you know there's a different type of
nervousness with being on the tonight
show when you have to
when you have when you're in charge of
the all the technical side of it
from your own home but we we had slotted
to shoot
um our carpool vlog
that we do every month for the mythical
society
like a 20 minute basically unedited us
driving in a car
but we had to figure that out we were
sitting in separate cars
filming it in the split screen in our
each of our driveways
and i i was so keyed up about being
on fallon and frustrated about
being in having to process all this
additional
things that i just didn't feel like
could fit in my brain
and i kind of felt like i could burst
into
tears anymore i felt like that a few
times
but the uh and that carpool vlog
became like the most raw and honest
in not in a near biscuits kind of way
but in like uh
hey we're about to be on fallon i don't
i what are we gonna wear
oh yeah remember that it just became a
very like
we're having a conversation that we
would we just needed to have
and we were making content at the same
time and it was like
we were gearing up for this thing and
processing how it felt to get ready to
be on the tonight show
um i'm glad we have that documented
because to me that was the that's the
that was the professional feeling
of quarantine like what was captured in
that carpool vlog but then the payoff
was this thing that
we got to i mean one of the highlights
2019 was like
wrapping the first song that we ever
wrote
while playing with the roots on the
tonight show the year before
and then a year later jimmy's like at
his house
we're at our homes it's just it was just
so surreal
it's like there's so many moments this
year of like
especially as it was on on
unpacking itself it's like this can't
really be happening
it's like i've never i've never
experienced something that it
that so consistently felt like a dream
or a nightmare and oscillated between
the two
very frequently so
the fallon hug is like the beautiful
silver lining
that to me represents everything
production that we
uh put ourselves through well i'm glad
you put it on your list
again i think we have a shared list i
think we just have a top 20. yeah
well i'm just saying that the reason
that i didn't again is
i that that period of time was so
frustrating and
the fallout thing was one of the
highlights but making the show at home
which was seemed sweet and uh
endearing for for a few episodes became
a real frustration uh
in a chore in a lot of ways and
for whatever reason just very few people
like
a lot less people watched it i think it
was you know just a different thing
we're not together
um but i'm glad it's on your list number
six for me
this isn't something that my wife and i
discovered for the first time but it is
something that we connected over
maybe in a new a new way
oh you talking about a position no i
didn't discover any new positions for
sorting the mail i think i figured them
all out
challenge accepted you want me to send
you a diagram
of all the different ones i'll tell you
what you're missing okay
watching trashy reality tv
we've been here i've done a couple i
think i did a whole episode essentially
about
married at first sight uh
and maybe also 90 day fiance
man we love some trashy reality tv we
love just
we're watching the bachelorette right
now which the bachelorette is almost not
trashy enough for us
it's almost too like respectable like
the people on the bachelorette like the
dudes on the bachelorette
are i mean
there's some that are they embarrass
themselves on a regular basis
but they don't embarrass themselves
enough
and to a degree that is pleasing enough
to me personally
i i need here's what i need when it
comes to trashy reality
okay i need people who
just make one bad decision after another
just like an avalanche about yeah just
yeah and i
and i need it i need it non-stop
and i and i need to cut from one person
making a really bad decision to another
person making a really good decision
and then figuring out who made the worst
decision
and i don't know what it says about me
but first of all
apparently this is the case with many of
y'all because
hey these shows tend to be incredibly
popular
but every time i've talked about them a
bunch of people have the most response i
ever get
on twitter is when is people talking
about these shows because
anyway well you realize you're doing it
again my wife and i you're talking about
the show
you're not talking about whites
not talking about you uh well no i
thought about why
it's i'm just messing i guess it's
because it's people making bad decisions
but i just don't want the next 30
minutes to be talking about the
bachelorette oh that's good i don't want
to yeah let me tell you some details
um but it is our little time in fact
tonight we're gonna watch an episode but
uh we connect it's funny we're
connecting with each other
we're both on our phones seeing what
people said about it when they watched
it
we're usually a little bit behind we're
also watching on the west coast so we're
watching
we're seeing the tweets that people made
about it when they watch the east coast
feed
and you don't have to really pay
attention and you know when you look up
it's just going to be somebody making a
bad decision or saying something stupid
and there's just something my wife and i
have bonded deeply
over this my number six
in stark contrast to
to your last entry is uh the black lives
matter movement
okay so yeah i'm making a
a hard turn here into uh
into some meaningful and potentially
heavy waters but um
you know it was i just
it's b it's it's such a pivotal point
in history i i actually still feel
you know whenever i start to talk about
it i get
really hesitant because i'm like who am
i
to talk to to talk about this
or to just to figure out what to say or
what if i say the wrong thing or the
right thing there's still that residual
thing that's happening
but for me it's
learning that you know what i'm engaged
in this
and this is not just something that i
can hold at arm's length they're further
away
i need to i need to look at these issues
i need to become educated that's
that that's what this year was in terms
of me
uh stopping and pain
and paying more attention to the
movement
and also i just want to give a shout out
to all the mythical bees to
uh you know we we had we had a
fundraiser early on
and then there was there was lots of
donations made to a variety of charities
associated with black lives matter
movement
and it was it was extremely meaningful
to me to
um to do
to do something and to to make up my
mind to
uh to be a part of
to be a force for good and to try
my best to figure out how i do that
and whether that's as a company or as an
individual
and as as a family i think it's and
do i have it figured out and am i am i
tooting any type of horn
i certainly hope it doesn't seem like it
but
i would be remiss if i didn't put it on
the list
and say that i mean this is a it was a
pivotal moment
for me personally to have
this level of interaction with such with
black lives matter
in such an important movement and it
also made my list in a slightly
different way but i'll wait to share
that when i get there but yeah i think
that
um yeah this was a this was a year
um
to to be clear you know it's these
issues
um have been things that we have
personally cared about
for in for a quite a while
but i think that there is sometimes we
were like
it's you know okay there's step one is
caring
like admitting that there is a problem
embedding that
you might even be a part of the problem
right um
step two is
to doing something about it and i think
and
and part of that has been being a
student because
again like you said i mean i mean we
we're not gonna
um we're not the ones with the ideas
but we're in a position where um
the things that we say the things that
we commit to are
impactful and powerful we have that's a
privilege and i think that
this is a year where being a student
reading books
where people who have looked at these
issues black voices who have
really considered these things in a way
that we
could never consider them personally but
being able to appreciate
that perspective and learn from it and
kind of be a student
for me this is you know it kind of for
me this year kind of represented going
from
being concerned and feeling like yeah
something needs to be done
about this to begin to listen to people
who have been saying that and actually
taking action for years
and saying okay how can we how can we be
supportive and be a part of that
and i'll talk a little bit more about a
personal thing related to that
what's
number five is the all-day
live stream that we did relatively
recently
i mean there has been some dispute over
whether or not doing it from nine to
five was all day
but for us that was all day um
but you know we didn't really know what
we were getting ourselves into
with this uh you know we did the live
stream
that benefited inner city arts a charity
that we have been wanting to partner
with
for a while and had not really given the
nature of this year have been given an
opportunity to do it
um and
you know people influencers or whatever
you want to say doing
charity live streams it's not a new
thing but it's something was new for us
and we if we were like if we're going to
do this we want to do it in a way that's
effective and actually makes a
difference but we want to do it in a way
that's mythical
you know we want to do it in a way that
is entertaining
um and our team did
an incredible job of pulling together
the live stream
and then the mythical beasts did an
incredible job
of showing up and giving well he's over
350 thousand dollars for inner city arts
yeah i was blown away and i will say you
know what we're in alignment this is my
number five
oh wow as well stars align you know i
i went home that night after the live
stream and ended and
you know i just was just processing and
every way that i looked at the
experience
like if it was the work that inner city
arts is doing
and how i just you know i could just
feel i know what it feels like to
to have to raise money or as part of a
non-profit
and it's sometimes it feels very
thankless
you know so i i got great joy from
knowing
how it how it must have felt to the
inner city arts
people who dedicated their lives and
at at times you might feel
underappreciated or forgotten to have
that vote of confidence from
people all over the world was
tremendously moving
to look at like you're saying to look at
our team and to say
how it was within the context of their
job but i could tell that everyone
involved
went above and beyond and outside of the
scope of their normal work
to to give of themselves to make this
happen
it was extremely i got a lot of joy from
that
you know um like seeing
our kids get involved
and you know calling our parents and
getting them
involved in it and making a decision to
bring back former employees like mike
and alex and jen
and um have them show up and celebrate
basically imply that like you guys are
have moved on from working with us
we're not employing you anymore but
you're still doing great things out
there in the world and we still have
this connection that
you know we're it felt good to still be
connected and to bring them back in and
to have this extended family
and but ultimately to make a decision to
that it
it was a family affair you know i saw
that
one of the comments afterward was you
know i'm
one mythical beast i'm sorry i can't
remember your handle specifically said
i love being a part of this family
because
we decided we weren't going to bring in
guests and we weren't going to
you know we weren't going to make it one
of those telethon type things which is
great and we we love being a part of
that too but
for it to be our thing in partnership
with inner city arts
was something that i think
just like i said and there's many more
ways but every way i would look at it
from any angle
it was just something that was brought a
lot of joy
to to inv to invest in something
you know in the arts well it's kind of
mythicality coming full circle
because we're doing something that we're
having fun doing it it's entertaining
there's a lot of light hearted moments
and fun moments
but it's directly doing something for
good which
there's a lot of indirect good that we
hear comes from the stuff that we do
where it's like oh this helped me get
through a difficult time or whatever and
of course we do give to charity
but to do something that is so directly
tied to a cause like that was
it felt really good that's why i was my
number five too man so you're number
four
number four okay we went on
a trip with our boys two of us
uh and all four of our boys i got two
he's got two
to death valley did a multi-day camping
trip
and what we're gonna do this is my
number four again
was it was a great trip but we're going
to do a whole episode where we talk
about this so i'm not going to go into
any details
i think we can kick off like the top of
the year okay so let's devote it to
this trip like because there's a there's
a handful of stories
it's just that things happened that the
things that happened
things always happen yeah yeah so it's
like we got to give you a whole episode
of uh of our time in death valley with
our
with our boys so that can be the next
episode well we're taking a break
a holiday break and then we're coming
back at the top of the year
uh so that can be the first in january
so did you put it on your list
or did you say no i'll just say no
didn't put it on my list
but was it one of your top 10 favorite
things
no because it's not on my list
i mean again wow my number four man the
order
doesn't matter it could be on my list i
mean i also went to
i went to you know my trip to joshua
tree
isn't on the list my trip to the my
beach trip isn't on the list but there's
like they should be
yeah this can only be so big um my
number four
is uh
starting and and doing the listening
party with britain
so that's that's my number three too oh
it is
[Laughter]
so i mean britain lived with us all last
year
uh he made my he made my top 10 last
year
and then he moved out and especially
with quarantine being shut down it's
like we didn't we didn't see each other
and we actually
we kind of fell out of touch didn't like
each other even though he lived
he's just over there in in burbank he's
not far away but like we couldn't get
together
right and so one day we're just you know
i'm like you know i need to reconnect
with him and we were talking and i was
like talking about how i missed
uh we started talking about music and i
was like you know what let's just
i miss us talking about music that's
what we would stay up late at night
you know just like standing around in
the kitchen just talking you know how he
is
you get him talking about music i keep
talking three hours later you're still
talking about music
and we would just play songs for each
other he's an encyclopedia you play
songs for each other
um and i was like you know what let's
and i'm just looking for things that
become like
connection amidst this covid thing
and i wanted to reconnect and i'm like
let's let's let's start making playlists
let's collaborate on a playlist and that
can just be something that can be a way
that we can have a project and we can be
talking to each other
and then we're like screw it let's just
let's do it on
instagram if john mayer can have a an
instagram live
yeah anybody can and you know lily and i
were that almost made the list like me
and lily watching current mood were like
we were obsessed with that until he
stopped doing it yeah
he became an obligation for him too yeah
yeah um
i was like we can do that so we we just
we made it a live stream but it was
very much about the two of us connected
and anybody who wanted to like share on
that music they could do it
and still can on my instagram but um
it just it was a very special time for
us to
because we would talk throughout the
week and get a kick out of building
these playlists
and then we would experience it together
on this live stream and it was
especially early on it was just an
opportunity for us to process
at many times like the emotions of
going through quarantine and
because music is so important to both of
us it it's
it's like there's this really
experiencing
the the soul connection that that music
can provide
uh connecting to your own soul but then
also connecting to somebody else and
then
really i mean it was it bonded us
at a time when we could have our our
relationship could have
could have moved further apart i find it
interesting that
like at this point
the way that i approach things i started
to approach it very
like okay well this is how we got to do
it and this is what it's about and then
you know and
i started making it about the wrong
things and like i was like hey i need to
take a break from this because
things are getting busy here at work
again so for like november we
like took a break from it and um
because it it because it started
becoming about something else
and about an obligation to somebody
besides
just me and britain hanging out yeah um
things don't have to last forever things
don't have to last forever but it
um it's it was
there were a handful of lifelines that
have gotten me
through and that was certainly one of
them and it's and will
always be very special uh to me
and i know to him too we had a lot of
big laughs too
uh you know those big laughs
the laughs that come in the midst of
when you just feel like crap it's like i
mean it's
this there's few things more therapeutic
maybe there's nothing more therapeutic
than a good laugh at the right time when
you really need it
and so that's what a listening party
that's
that's the soul of that uh
for me that's my number four my number
three
is related to the black lives matter
movement
and you know when everything was
happening
uh in in specifically
kind of the catalyst that brought things
into just you know brought this issue to
the forefront again was the murder of
george
george floyd right and um
i i've talked before there's been a few
times when i've written something
on i'll write a medium article about
something and
usually the thing that gets me to the
point where i feel like i have something
to say
or there's something i have to say that
i can't not say is when i just see
people saying things uh
online and i'm just like i kind of feel
like i can speak into this
and i get this i get something in my
mind on my heart and i just have to say
it i have to just get it out right
um and i was when all
when everything was coming out and
everyone was everyone most people who
have
any sort of public persona were
acknowledging
the movement in some way right and
for the same reasons that you were
pointing out in the beginning
is just like well it seems to me that a
lot of times
i'm not speaking for all white guys but
it tends to be kind of a white guy thing
to be like well i've got something to
say and you should listen to me
right anybody can do it but you know we
have a pretty bad track record of
believing that whatever we have to say
is the most important thing to say
and uh so i was sensitive to that
knowing that i don't bring a lot of
education
and a lot of personal experience and
perspective into this issue so again i
was like i want to listen
but i also want to be a responsible
you know ally
and it hit me that the way that i could
be involved
was i saw a lot of people saying things
related to the incident with george
floyd
that sort of reflected some things that
i might have said
in my past that are kind of based on
where i come from and you know the
mentality that i had growing up
and kind of the lack of experience and
lack of knowledge that i had and lack of
empathy
frankly that i had for people outside of
my own experience
and so that's when i wrote what i called
letter to a white man which was
essentially writing a letter to the old
rhett
and saying hey listen you know i know
that you actually do care about these
things but a lot of the things that you
think and say
and the way that you react to these
things are contributing to the problem
they're not actually solving the problem
so i wrote that kind of kind of
self-conscious about it again because it
was ironically a white dude saying
something but again i was a white dude
saying something to
a white dude um and my former self to be
specific
and the thing that was really
encouraging about it was
the response i mean sure like a lot of
people were
you know upset with me or pointed out
all the things that they thought
all the places where i was wrong but
there were a number of people who
communicated
whether it be through like an instagram
message or something on twitter
who said hey you know this was
legitimately
and impacted me um
because a lot of the things that you
said are the things that i have been
thinking about this
and it actually gave me a chance to
reflect on that and to consider a
different
perspective and just one person
saying that would have been worth it uh
but the reaction was super positive and
enough and it was just it was very it
for me it was
i wasn't doing this for it i wasn't
doing it for attention and i wasn't
doing it to get any
a pat on the back i was doing it simply
because i know there was a lot of people
out there
like me right and i thought i had
something to say to me
um and i hear from
some people like that uh
is what you were that that was your aim
yeah
um so that was super super encouraging
stuff i bet that felt good because it's
you know it's
it's it's the same reason that the live
stream is on
on the on the list because it's
doing wanting to do so realizing that we
do have a platform
and and again that pervasive question of
what's the right thing to do with this
opportunity that we have
and you know how do you you've got
things that you want to say and you get
you know it's it's it can be a
treacherous path to figure out how to
take a stand
on issues or how to make a difference
and
um you can be intimidated into doing
nothing
even within your own mind you know not
by anyone else even
um so it's
i i mean that's something that
i've taken from been inspired by with
the black lives matter movement
is that you can find a way to
to to do something
uh and yeah i'm i'm i'm super proud of
what you wrote
and how you went about it and it's also
not on my list
well thanks uh my number three is is a
painful one
and uh you know i'm i i might cry i
don't know exactly what i'm gonna say so
i just feel
emotional about it but i wanted to put
this on the list again because it was
it was an impactful moment for me
this year and it's uh um
and maybe there's a silver lining to it
but it's just something that i'd
you know i'd i haven't talked about but
it has was a defining moment in in my
2020 and that is
that when my grandma who
i've always called my nanny my mom's mom
passed away
uh she passed away in june and
um i couldn't go home right
and it it hurt a lot and it
it still hurts uh
because there's you know it's it it
wasn't
it wasn't um a surprise
and it wasn't uh it it didn't happen
quickly
and that that's in some ways that made
it
much more difficult um
you know last i was looking back at my
my my evernotes which sometimes are
dated but it's definitely not a journal
uh of like just
my record of my memories from
thanksgiving
last year and you know
i was like who's who's not gonna who was
here this thanksgiving is not gonna be
here next thanksgiving and that and i
was thinking about nanny and you know
when you go and visit her and i think i
talked about that
some about that experience like every
year you go home as your grandparents
get older it's like maybe this is the
last year i'm spending with her
and living in california maybe this is
the
the last time i'm seeing her in person
right
um was that thanksgiving and it it turns
out that it was
in it so it is nice to have that
awareness and to have those memories of
this may be it so i'm gonna you know
i'm going to acknowledge that
and so the i'm grateful for that that
that
the last time i saw her in person was
that
there was kind of an understanding that
that might that might be it
i will say that it was that way for a
couple of years actually
um she wasn't and she was at home
um and um and they brought in hospice
and she was
so she was she was made comfortable
as she passed and but the but leading
but and that was about a week and a half
and it was
it was it was it was excruciatingly
difficult
to come to grips with the fact that the
the right decision
was not to fly home at that time
um it it wasn't simply
just the covet of it all it was i mean
there were there were a number of
factors which impacted
you know um my immediate family
and um i'll just say that
the accumulation of all the all the
factors
led to being the right decision but it's
like there's still this doubt in your
mind it's like
should i go home or not and it's like
it didn't it never felt great it still
doesn't feel great it
in some ways it doesn't feel real still
having not been home
you know um
i you know it's i haven't had the
experience of going back in the house
and her not being there uh
and i know a lot of people
and and she didn't have covet just as a
side note but i know a lot of people
have lost a lot of loved ones and it's
been extremely painful to not be able to
see them as their passing
you know and but they're right there you
know i was across the country and it was
excruciating so my heart goes out to all
those people who are on the other side
of a pane of glass
having to watch someone pass
um and
i knew that i would write i knew that i
would have spoken at her funeral
and um
when she was planning her funeral
and saying she was saying she was saying
what she was telling
her her sisters what she wanted to wear
and you know and she said
you know i want i want link to sing a
song at the funeral
and i i she didn't quite i don't think
she quite
understood that i wasn't gonna be able
to be there and so it
it broke my heart to know that that she
i couldn't deliver on that you know um
but i wrote a eulogy and i asked
and i emailed it to the to the pastor
who was already speaking to
to to read and at the funeral
and um i had mailed them
the record that we made for the mythical
society where we covered silver wings
the merle hacker song uh and it you know
i knew it was my aunt vicki
who who for basically her entire
adult life lived with my nanny like
the oldest sister youngest sister lived
together
even when my papa was alive
aunt vicki still lived there and then
when he passed it was just the two of
them and now
it's just aunt vicki and she she has
another sister that she's close with and
spends a lot of time with
thank goodness but like i'm well i
mailed them the record because it was
her favorite song but then
um that was the solution they actually
played silver
our i didn't even know that yeah they
played our rendition of silver wings
at at the funeral service and then they
read
my eulogy and um but it you know it was
it was just tough not to be there you
know it was
uh and it's just the
uh so there's just like
there's a lot of pain associated with it
and uh
you know a lack of closure uh
i think until i can get back home again
i think it'll still
kind of be in the
the wound will be a little more open
than
than i would hope but um
it's my number three because it's it's
it's such a poignant
milestone that uh
i think it i don't know how it's changed
me but you can just feel that like okay
that this this is one of those things
that shapes you as a person
when you go through something when it's
it's so frustrating so painful to not be
able to be there
for your family
well it's not on my list
but thanks for sharing um
i have one that probably is on your list
and that is
um my number two
us telling our stories the lost years
on this very podcast which i guess we
did in january
uh we did it
yep i mean in january the first two
episodes came out and then in february
is when like your deconstruction story
came out and then mine and that yeah so
it was kind of january
february and this is my number two as
well okay all right so we are
up again we're in we're syncing up once
again
you know i don't think boy
what a weird year what a very very weird
yeah year that this happened this year
and then
cove had happened but i think we decided
we had decided we were going to do this
at the end of 2018 october november of
2019
and so we had the sense that it was
going to be like
we're doing it early in 2020 but it was
going to be something that would
maybe reshape the course of ear biscuits
or
we didn't know what it would lead to i
was antsy
to tell to tell the story right and i
and i think that
uh for me it had been kind of a long
time coming and
you know one of the reasons i wanted to
kind of tell our story
is because it was such a you know our
background
of growing up as christians as
not just christians but evangelical
christians who it was the
centerpiece of our life and then the
centerpiece of our career
in the early days um it was so
there was so much tension in being
vulnerable and personal you know
personal
and talking about our lives and you know
mostly in this
in this medium of your biscuits but we
talk about ourselves
all the time we're constantly kind of
telling stories and stuff
and to have this giant piece of your
past
that informs who you are and constantly
finding ways to gloss over it
and you know there were so many
tangential things
you know about our career in the path to
where we're at right now and the fact
that we were
we worked with campus crusade for a
while and it's kind of the reason that
we got into comedy
all these things that we weren't able to
say to me there was al
always this like kind of shame
associated with
our past but also a shame of not being
honest about it
that had just created this tension yeah
for me telling the story
and kind of just saying here it is
without any
apologies we're just going to tell you
the whole story
of where we were and where we are now
and how we got here
to me it kind of just un it opened
something up
within me right uh in the way that
the way that i think about the things
that we talk about on this podcast now
it's kind of changed
pretty dramatically for me it's like if
there's something that comes up and it's
we would avoid anything that got into
spirituality at all right if it was just
like well this kind of gets into like
talking about god or religion or faith
or whatever
we would avoid it and it's so strange
for people who that is such
a big part of who we are to not be able
to talk about it
um i'm not i'm not even really going to
get into the i mean the response was
overwhelming in every sense of the word
both positive and negative and the way
that it kind of transformed
people's perspective of us
both for the good and for the bad we
gained fans we lost fans
um but really for what it was so
impactful for me because i just felt
like it was this
ironically it's the way that you
describe
becoming a christian a lot of times is a
huge burden is lifted off of you
and you have this feeling this sense of
relief when you
give your life to god um
ironically for me kind of talking about
how
i'm in a completely different place and
no longer consider myself
a christian or a person of faith in that
way specifically
it was a huge burden that was lifted off
of me i think for me it was a milestone
in my spiritual journey because
it in a lot of ways it said okay now
it i can not that i couldn't move
forward or i needed to talk about it in
order to move forward
but it was ok it was it's kind of
it it kind of was that i don't know it
it
i was like okay i can i can document
what brought me to this point in my
spiritual journey
the exercise of talking about it and the
preparation leading to that really
helped me make sense of it for myself so
that now i can
i it made it it made it so i could move
forward
in a way that i don't think i could
because i did
i hadn't processed it enough i mean i
definitely
really began
to appreciate my relationship with guilt
and you know this was the year that
i started therapy and
um
and am continuing my spiritual journey
and a journey
of of openness and um
self-discovery as part of that too but
it's i i'm
i'm moving forward in in in openness
and i'm also saying all right i'm still
coming to grips with
what is my relationship to guilt uh
in addition to what is my relationship
to god and to to belief
and expectations as
as a human and or as a father
or a husband you know it's so again
these are all things that i'm
i'm still very much in process i mean
who's not in process but i do feel like
it it it released
released me in some ways and then gave
me
a trajectory to continue to move forward
so it's it's not about a label it's not
about coming to a conclusion
or a new affiliation or
a news like an allegiance to
some other system religious or otherwise
um but it's a
it it's there's momentum
um i do find it interesting that like
i i still don't know where talk about
momentum kovid really kind of
truncated the experience you know we put
these things out there
there was a lot of response and there
was you know i had to
you know i had to go on a hike and clear
my head and figure out how to deal with
the fact that like so many people
it turns out really cared about the fact
that we talked about this
and they all didn't agree with us you
know and
um but then covid hit
and it kind of in a lot of ways
we just you know it felt like it didn't
happen well
i had to get reacquainted with the fact
that like remember january february
this big milestone moment happened a
number two
number two on our list you know it's
like it seems like ages ago had to get
re-equipped and we had specifically
we had done an interview for a major
publication that
is related to christian faith um
that never never was published because
uh
covet hit and ev everybody's pre and
then we were featured in another
another publication um
like two pretty popular christian
publications were gonna
do stories on this thing uh and then
that it just never happened and
the people who were talking about it had
a whole lot of other stuff to talk about
and
you know maybe that was a blessing in
disguise i mean it was a as we
again one of the few times that i've
written something to know medium was in
response to
the responses that we were processing at
the time the four of us
the two of us and our wives um
it was such you know it was i'm i've
absolutely no regrets i'm
so i i obviously you always
wish you might have said something a
little bit differently you know because
you know that's just the way it goes
when you decide to talk about something
um but the decision to share that story
is something that i am just incredibly
grateful for
it was a coming out it really was 100
and it i mean it's it's so difficult
it was so difficult to to to be
a certain person and to be so open about
so many things but not be open about
something that's so core to who you are
you know it's and that's why i think
using that terminology is
is applicable like um
though it's i'm not gonna say it's to
the same degree or the same
experience as somebody who's who's who's
coming out of the closet would have but
like
i can relate at least a little bit and
it's because it's
this is who this is who i am and i you
know and i don't want to be
i don't want to be ashamed or scared
about it
and it makes such a i mean that that is
at its core
is that relief because it's like hey i'm
just being
and openly sharing who i am you know
take it as you will and we've also
um
throughout our career you know we've
we've been
people pleasers in a lot of ways you
know it's like we're pretty we're pretty
tame we're pretty safe
there's a lot of people from a lot of
different backgrounds that enjoy the
things that we do
and we have we have a pretty broad
appeal
by design we want things to be
accessible and we want it to be a break
we don't want it to be affiliated with
any particular view
hey it's just you know take a load off
and come enjoy this thing that we made
but to take we didn't really take a
stand as much as we just told our story
but
it was interpreted as taking a stand by
a lot of people and
uh i don't think we've ever experienced
that level of
scrutiny and criticism and that was
something that
was very difficult at the time but again
as someone who
uh struggles with
and places too much value on other
people's opinions of me
um it's good to have those opinions be
very very
loud and negative so that you can
detach a little bit more from those
expectations which kind of leads me into
number one
okay we're to our number ones um which i
think
in some ways was at least as 2020 is
concerned kind of a
a culmination of
just the per kind of what you were
getting at which the beginning of
sort of the next stage of what
spirituality is to me
um and i did a whole podcast on it so
i'm not gonna go into too many details
but it was my
my solo trip that i took earlier in the
year
um and again i
there were details of things that
happened to me
uh sort of just things that
i kind of realized or came to grips with
what how whatever the word you want to
use is
that i'm not going to share because i
feel like it was for me and i'm not
trying to make it for
you um but i think that it's
very much tied to the fact that we told
our stories because there was
uh there was a little bit of stagnation
right because there's this like i'm
i've left this thing and i don't know
what i'm going to
but i don't want to
jump into some other kind of
fundamentalism
right i don't want to jump from one
fundamentalism from one
ideological rut to another
it was just something i was trying
really hard not to do
and it's very difficult to do that it's
very difficult
uh to maintain sort of an openness
and an openness to
spirituality in general when you kind of
feel like you've sort of been duped in a
way
but my trip which is something that i
had been trying to organize it's
difficult
especially this year to sort of
logistically organize
going off when your father husband and
business owner
for i think it ended up being like six
days and five nights
but right from the beginning it was just
such a rich
experience and i haven't even totally
processed it there was
there was a lot of journal writing
speaking the journal and it wasn't just
evernote it was
a literal physical journal in a literal
space pin you should take a picture of
the pages in case you lose
i thought about that in fact just the
other day i was like where is that
journal
and i was like i can't find my journal
it was it was my backpack scan it or my
book bag as you say
um but there
you know i think it is going to be the
beginning of
a tradition for me probably annual
i don't know um i hope at least annual
i actually like reinvested i put some
money into my
my uh my truck got it since
since that camping trip i've got a
drawer you saw my drawer yeah you got a
drawer a drawer installed in my
fj that makes camping like you can be
ready to go i could go tonight if i
wanted to it's all in the drawer
got everything in a drawer uh and just
the value of
escape solitude
personal reflection and just
understanding that man when you
this is this isn't just me this is
everybody like
everybody got their own [ __ ] that they
got to deal with
on a daily basis and the
responsibilities and the busyness
and the distractions and all the things
that
keep you from really checking in
with yourself and checking in with
yourself
in a meaningful way in an intentional
way
that's designed to kind of like hey
let's keep this train going in
a direction in the with the right
direction whatever you want to call it
um yeah yeah it's easy to forget that
your life is yours alone
you know ultimately yeah yeah and
it's you know i again this is the case
for everybody i think that
you can really begin to over
identify not only with your
opinions and positions and you know i
i tend to you know i can fall into
opinions and arguments and that kind of
thing
but you can also over identify with your
different stations in life
now first of all if you're a father if
you're a husband if you're a boss
sure you should lean into that and be
the best that you can
but when you are only those things and
you only exist in relationship to other
people
or as to what you can be for someone
else
which is a listen hey you want to be
selfless and you want to be a servant of
other people
but sometimes you can you can get lost
you can lose yourself
in that i can also get lost in your own
personality
oh yeah yeah and and to me
it was like taking that solo trip
was everybody's got like a big
um you know they got you you you got
your own stink that you're carrying
around with you your own stank right
from the from your own i i just call it
my own [ __ ]
right i've in fact just last night i
told uh
jesse before therapy out because i was
like my therapy was kind of scheduled
for a different night than it was
because of our trip to death valley and
we had a pretty difficult day business
wise not yesterday just
in in terms of just dealing with a lot
of things all at once and sort of being
a boss
was demanding yesterday right and uh
i got home and i and i was just like man
i don't want to go to therapy
tonight i know i'm going to i just don't
want to
you know because i told jesse i was like
sometimes you just don't want to deal
with your own [ __ ]
because that's what therapy is right but
for me that's what the solo trip was it
was
it was like all right i've stripped away
all my
responsibilities and relationships
and here i am sitting alone oh there it
is
there's my big bag of [ __ ] let's
start unpacking it a little bit
um and it was good i mean turns out it
stinks pretty bad but i think
you were in a hot spring too i did leave
some of the [ __ ] in some of the hot
springs
so that's my number one and i and i hope
that i can
i can do it again my number one is
is um if if if i were to translate
my like my
psyche and my emotional well-being to a
physical location
it will be my garage so my number one
is the fact that i
have my garage remodeled and then i
reorganized all of it in the wonderful
cabinetry and
listen as a as a as a person who only
saw
your garage before and after i can say
it's is it
it's a thing of beauty oh yeah i gotta i
gotta post one of those pictures
actually kind of the thing i was
thinking about is your garage
is so well organized that it sort of
feels like an ikea it kind of
sort of feels like something needs to be
re
like misplaced here like a sock or
something
or like like an oil stain or something
needs to happen because right now it
feels
so good it feels like a showroom i just
go out there and stand yeah i mean i'm
saying it's so
good it's a little impersonal all right
i got that's not my number one
i mean christy was like i was telling
her the list last night and she was like
you didn't put your garage on the list
you know they get they give me such a
hard time i gave
once once everything was organized i
gave each member of the
house their own personalized tour of it
what i i like took each person out there
and i gave them a tour of it
i was so proud they didn't they didn't
seem to care
uh christy cared some because she helped
me she helped do the redesign of some of
it but no
i didn't put that in my top ten that's
just an honorable mention
my number one is at the same time you're
on a solo trip i was on my solo trip
with my wife okay so you're trying to
make me look bad no
yeah the van the van trip uh i didn't do
a solo trip but i
i i need to do one i mean i think i got
a bag of [ __ ]
i mean i'd i probably do
uh i don't know maybe you've been
filling up my bag
either way i don't know it works no but
i
i i want to do that but
for reasons i'll get into um a little
bit
that you know christy and i really
needed this trip
and when i talked about it
before in in the
podcast where i talked about it christy
pointed out after listening to it she
was like you know you didn't say
that there was our 20th wedding
anniversary
and it's like well and i was like well
that's because well i didn't say
anything but i was like okay
in her mind and i guess for both of us
it it it was
we had to cancel our our wedding
anniversary
uh we were going to go to big sur i
thought i did mention that she says i
didn't
but so it was i mean we were due for
that
to to to be able to celebrate 20 years
of being together
but um as i described we went we went to
utah and we
one of the hikes we took was in bryce
canyon
which is this beautiful
place that uh has all these
mud hoodoos that you walk through
and we walked around once a wonderful
term uh are we having a conversation
we've already had
a hoodoo i don't know we talked about it
yeah it's a technical term
that's what they call them walking
around this one corner
and i saw a piece of paper on the ground
like somebody littered
there's there's four rocks on it holding
it in place and it is a letter
to people along the trail now
technically you shouldn't do this you
shouldn't be writing letters and leaving
them on a trail
but because what if everybody did that
then there'd be letters all over the
place and it would just be
literal it would be wrecked it wouldn't
be a letter it'd be litter only one
person
left a letter and i took a picture of it
i didn't even read the whole thing but i
would like to read it now i didn't share
this in the previous podcast
um and then through the lens of this
letter i just want to
i can i can unpack why the van tripp was
my number one
i will say and i've got sort of a side
view of your
your screen here yep i have not been
able to interpret
what that is like i
from my angle which is i'm just kind of
seeing this
it looked like there was some crazy
stationary
like you know you can get like
stationary that has like a border
and then has like lines that somebody
strikes cursive oh you thought that the
dirt
around the paper was part of all like a
printed thing that like you would get at
like a wedding but no it's just a
picture you took of
a letter on dirt yeah a hand written
letter uh just placed onto some rocks
the breeze wouldn't blow it away hello
if you're reading this
you made it to a beautiful place on
earth
oh the importance of roaming i will say
the one thing quarantine has taught us
is to free our minds they are meant to
wander
and you are meant to be here i am so
happy to be in this canyon
for a few years i've been battling lupus
and fibromyalgia it can be very
devastating to experience
at 26 years old but i have realized
everyone is fighting a personal battle
maybe you're out here to escape or start
a new journey
whatever it may be it has purpose and
you are worthy
of self-discovery the letter continues
but i'll stop there
um you know i i don't want to get into
too many details
about um
the summer that that our family
went through because it's it's
a lot of it is christy's story to tell
and not mine
um but
it it definitely rings true that uh
everyone is fighting a personal battle
and there was a there was a personal
battle that was going on
in our home um like uh christy was
struck with uh a debilitating
uh level of anxiety
associated with physical symptoms that
uh she was having in the midst of covid
and um
we hear an anecdotal evidence of
so many people struggling
internally mentally and emotionally
um with within the context of
covid and quarantine isolation
health anxiety you know the list
goes on and and impacts people in
in so many different ways um
but uh for christy and for us as
as a couple and then as a family
i would say there was there was a couple
of pockets
of time and you know what i'm talking
about
where um it was
extremely difficult for her and
for us to face together uh it was
something that we faced together
uh but i would say it was
it was probably the most challenging
um uh
if you had a if you had a concentration
of struggle
uh that we had to walk through
uh in in our in our 20 years of marriage
um and
it was
it was just uh it was a it was a scary
time for her
and for us and uh i know we talked about
it
and uh you know
uh you were you were tremendously
helpful
in that time and i've you know i want to
thank you again for that
and again i did
it's not a story that i want to tell but
you know if but it was
that was our personal battle that we
were fighting and there were
um there were times when i could do
nothing else except
engage in in in being there
with her through that and it was
i i can't i can't do anything else i
can't i can't be present
for work i can't be um
it was it was unlike anything i'd ever
experienced
it was and at times it was very uh
confusing and
scary i'll just say
but now you know i i can
i can speak from from the other side of
it and say that
um you know it's um
i i think this letter really rings true
to our experience in that uh
you know i mean she she she has lupus
and fibromyalgia
and says it can be very devastating to
experience
uh that but she realized that everyone
is fighting a personal battle
and that
everybody's on their own journey and
whatever
whatever it may be it has a purpose and
you are worthy of self-discovery
and i do think that that was our
experience
walking through the the the trials that
that we went through over the summer in
terms of
finding out what we were really made of
and as individuals and as a couple and
as a family and
um so going on this trip
was it was it was much more than just
rescheduling
a celebration of you know of our
anniversary
it was um
being together and it you know
everything that if if you rerun
everything that i described from that
trip
through the lens of the trials that we
had been through that i know i'm not
sharing the details of it's just that's
the level of meaning that puts this at
number one
for me because it was we needed it
so badly you know to have uh an
experience
together where we could focus on each
other and uh
it was it was very special until we were
almost killed by a guy who everybody
uh wanted to buy hot dogs from us you're
almost you know almost killed
which i think getting away from a
murderer
yeah it's actually that's like a number
one also puts things in perspective
uh it's been a difficult year for
so many people you know and it's
on a global scale and
so to to be able to look back on
our years and to to pull together 10
and have some honorable mentions and
to have made it through this year
and i mean it ain't over and who knows
what 2021 holds but having
having gone through 2020 i you know i i
feel like i'm a
i'm a better person for it
and uh i'm not inviting more trials in
2021 but um i'm
i i think that i'm more grateful
having gone having experience this year
and my heart goes out to the people who
are
are still in dire straits and they're
they're in the thick of it
so you know i i
i don't have answers but you know i have
empathy
and if it's if it's a comfort if you're
going through something
and it's a comfort to you
i'll just pass along what the letter had
to say again that whatever it may be it
has purpose and you are worthy of
self-discovery
uh yeah you know it has been such a
difficult
year and like you said it continues to
be very difficult
i think there is some light at the end
of the tunnel at this point
um but there's going to be scars
on families and on
you know people's psyches from just
going through
what they've gone through this year
people's livelihoods
businesses you know there's been a
there's been so many challenges
sometimes i i sort of imagine
what you know how when you're sick
just with like a cold not anything like
that covet but just like
just a cold and you can't breathe out of
your nose
and you think to yourself man when
i can breathe in my nose again i'm not
going to take it for granted
i'm going to smell so hard i'm going to
think about every breath
and then as soon as you can breathe
through your nose again most time you
don't even realize that you can breathe
through your nose again you just go on
about your business
breathing through your nose like some
professional athlete breather
taking it for granted i think about what
life is going to be like
i think about being able to just go to a
restaurant without
thinking about you know you know i'm not
going to any restaurants right now but
going out and not having to think about
everything you're touching and how close
you're getting to people and whether
you've got a mask on
and just living life again being able to
hug somebody without thinking about it
being able to gather with people again
man i hope i never take that stuff for
granted again
you might you might have had the
privilege of like knowing somebody who
lived through the depression you know
who's
you know would be a very old person at
this point but my
wife's grandmother who died in her 90s
recently
uh it had some memories of that time
and kind of came up in sort of an age of
scarcity
and you know she would use aluminum foil
or tin foil as she would call it
she put it on a dish and then she would
take it off the dish and she would roll
it back up and put it in the
drawer and she she was frugal and she
saved and she conserved
and it was because she had that
mentality um
i wonder sometimes like what are we
gonna carry that
can we get through the can we get to the
other side of the tunnel
and not take for granted the things that
um that we've been missing and
and just the struggles that people you
know when we get through this
collectively as a species because like
you said this is a global
thing well you know what i think it's up
to us
and you know so uh
and i think this exercise again i
cherish it every year but i think it's
just
i think it's all that more important
this year
for that reason so it's hey this
happened
but but these other things happen
too yeah there's things to be grateful
for and
and i can be grateful for for the trials
and the pain associated with
with it too in due time and i'm thankful
i'm thankful for this
you talked about the family and we have
a family here at mythical but this is a
this is a family this is a family thing
that what we have
and you listening to this i think
so many people have you know we've been
humbled many times that we've met people
uh in person back when we used to tour
but also just seeing people things say
things online about how the
the stupid stuff that we do and even in
the serious stuff that we talk about
how this has been meaningful for people
you know and i think about that with the
things that
entertain me you know this has been such
a difficult time
that the connections that you can make
with people online in the in the outlets
that entertain you i like to think of
this as more than just we're not just
here to entertain you but this is
we're having this ongoing discussion as
a family
um so thank you for those of you who
have stuck with us through 2020 and
yeah we have joined us in 2020 and
you're part of this mythical herd
and we're yeah we're honored that we
have a place at your
table and we have so to speak that we
have that we're part of your experience
and that we've been a part of your
2020 and uh part of your silver lining
we we're honored of course just like
every ear biscuit we end with a
recommendation and my recommendation
as this year comes to a close as this
season of your biscuits
comes to a close you know what
just relax that's my recommendation
just take the pressure off of yourself
relax reward yourself do something
that you enjoy for the sake of enjoyment
um you're gonna get through this year
you're gonna get through this time
and we will see you in the new year with
a new ear
biscuit that's right to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right
to watch the previous episode of your
biscuits click on the playlist to the
left and don't forget to click on the
circular icon to subscribe
if you prefer to listen to this podcast
it's available on all your favorite
podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best